[Musique]
alors nique d'où venez-vous de beaucoup
d'endroits depuis combien de temps vous
vivez ici quelques semaines des semaines
dans cette cabane je l'aime bien c'est
calme et désolé
si on est venu ici aujourd'hui c'est
pour parler de notre petit projet et de
son avancement je pense qu'en prime il
nous donnerait quelques armes qui font
passer en contrebande ne parle plus
jamais de la cargaison qui sont-ils
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
mon mari a vendu son âme au diable la
tête de ton mari en vérité et ce que toi
tu lui dois avec les membres de ta
famille
vous allez bien
il n'y a que deux possibilités
avec eux
soit ils vont vous tuer vous et votre
fils montez dans le camion
donc si vous ne partez pas
vous allez devoir faire avec
je ne vais pas tu es qui que ce soit je
n'ai pas dit vous
[Musique]